[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum what a great episode
today I I seldom I mean I like you know
my guests of course but uh this guy
I was enamored by his performance you
were you really were I really was I was
like you know I watch a lot of stuff and
I was like this guy
is an actor I mean that Clint Eastwood
movie I'm not going to mention names
right now because of the strike but um
the series that he's on just nominated
for Golden Globe the guy works
constantly uh the guy I'm talking about
is Paul Walter Hauser
Paul Walter Hauser career doing pretty
good he strikes a good balance between
um comedy and drama oh he can do both he
can do better effortlessly yeah he's
Adept at both comedy drama and uh you
know we talked about hanging out and
stuff and he invited me to something but
I I love the guy I totally want to hang
out with this guy he's just such a Down
to Earth dude
I hope you don't blow up too big I mean
I hope you blow up big but it doesn't
your head doesn't blow up all right Paul
don't do it to me
always come on the podcast always have
time for me
um look if you like this podcast if
you're here for Paul all we ask if you
enjoy it and you're like hey I wasn't
half bad
follow us on our handles Ryan at inside
of you pod on Twitter inside of your
podcast on Instagram and Facebook that's
correct and uh you can watch on YouTube
um listen uh we really appreciate if you
write a review helps the podcast we talk
about mental health and so much
different stuff and it's not your
typical podcast we don't think nor do
the people listening think hopefully you
won't think that and you'll uh
you'll join also if you want to join
patreon and support the podcast we could
use your help Patron Patron
patreon.com inside of you the inside of
you online store has amazing new zip up
IOU I just got the sweatshirts they're
awesome zip UPS I wear one
um so get those while they last and tons
of cool new tumblers and autographed
pictures of me and tons of stuff so
inside your online store
um Tom and I will be we're gonna get
right to the interview but also we're
going to be in Salt Lake City DC
Minneapolis in September then Rhode
Island
um I'll be in spooky Con in Orlando for
a horror convention and just November
December November
um
me and hater are going to go film our
show
yeah reality show we're gonna go do that
at the end of November
so a lot of good stuff I got a little
children's book coming out oh yeah and
uh Simon and Schuster are Distributing
so uh we'll inform you more as that
comes along the band is Sun spins my
band we perform every month at
stageit.com you can go to sunspin.com
and find out and get zooms with me and
Rob and uh we'll have to be posting new
videos we made and um the album's out
we're selling the vinyl uh sunspin.com
support the band the podcast all that
stuff and uh
Ryan went on a little trip with his dad
a little bonding experience yeah it was
great did you cry
uh no I didn't cry this time did he say
things like Ryan I'm really proudy and I
love you I mean yeah
hmm what's that like it's great
well we play guitar together when we go
camping and we wow that's cool
good bonding what do you play with songs
what did we play Supertramp no we
learned uh
uh The Beatles song two of us you know
just the two of us
uh but that's cool yeah and um James
Taylor oh yeah Eagles Eagles always
comes up so you play you played that in
the woods yeah did you see any Wildlife
no
there's no Wildlife no no why not
because we're deep in the room we're in
a very specific campsite oh so there's
animals so there's other people around
there yeah they didn't care that you
were playing guitar loudly yeah I just
want peace and quiet and these tears
folks are just effing it up all right
without further Ado let's get into it
let's get into Paul Walter Hauser it's
my
[Music]
mom
oh
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode and any we
air before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
you have such a good uh like radio voice
do I really yeah you do are you saying I
have a face already you suck no I did
not say that I said in in tune with you
also having a face for film and
television uh and you know
brothels uh I think you also have a
voice for radio or as the kids call it
podcasting or how about I always wanted
to do trailers but no one does them
anymore I'm obsessed with the old
trailer voices
the LaMontagne guy was that his name
something one Monte he passed away
didn't he he did he did I think from
some throat related uh no no no oh my
God that's why he said anywhere
I always loved the one who used to there
was a there was a voice over guy who
worked for like UPN WB probably back in
the day not not like right around the
time you were doing swallowville and he
would he was like so Earnest and kind of
all sounded like this older soothsayer
guy and he would talk like this he'd go
this week on an all-new Everwood
is that Everwood and he would be like I
don't know all new One Tree Hill and it
was like a serious voice that would like
maybe narrate a War documentary but he's
like talking about the relationship
between Treat Williams and the kid it's
just uh it's just a very very funny
thing to me so I'll be in the kitchen
and I'll just be like chopping
vegetables right or like pan frying
burgers and I'll be like I don't know
all new pan fried Burger to yourself one
cheeseburger will satisfy the Cravings
of Paul Hauser until he gets another
like I'll just like I just say dumb
stuff like that to a music does your
wife say shut up ever will you shut up
not so much shut up as an eye roll and
maybe she'll leave the room at some
point yeah that could have that's what
my dog does that to me would you rather
be told three choices okay
quiet
God
shut up
which one if you had to have someone say
it's something
it's hard I'm just picturing Kevin
Spacey saying that to Anthony let me no
oh that's Malkovich no quiet
shut up that's good no but uh
shut up or what's the third one third
one is
is no third one is
yeah quiet shut up and
I think the sh is is the most
belittling yeah it's like I I'm not even
gonna dignify you with words and it's
also like we shush dogs we shush
children yeah we don't shush adults you
shush an adult like you will see Rick
Moranis turn into you know the
incredible Hulk like a small man could
do a lot of violent damage by being shut
I choose quiet I think quiet's kind of
funny
or snap that's the worst don't snap at
people but I don't mind I always say
this to people it's a quiet place I had
an actor once do this to me I I was
cracking a joke because he was being
inappropriate and everybody around me
was on my side because they always are I
just had some freaking veteran actor
actually a dick and uh and
I I said something and at one point he
went to me he put his hand up and he
went ah
and I was like oh man did you were you
confrontational you just let it go I was
I was doing the thing where someone's
being inappropriate you crack a joke to
lighten the mood but the joke is also
pointing out the absurdity of how the
person's acting yeah and by the second
joke that person caught on and got
frustrated I got frustrated with a guy
on Set uh Michael Ironside remember him
I know him well not personally but um
scanners no when I think Mike Ironside
and I say right because we are dear
friends when I when I think Mike
Ironside I think of uh The Machinist oh
yeah Christian Bale yeah you know here's
the thing we're on set and I'm like
always goofing with everybody making the
crew laugh everybody's having fun yeah I
want to entertain and this guy is on Set
uh old school or whatever and I come on
and I'm joking I'm like you know I'm
doing like you know uh hey how are you
all right looks good on you though
Rodney yep and he and he's like there
and I he looks at me I put my hand down
he doesn't shake it goes
you're that guy huh
and I had my scanners poster in the
trailer and the way he said it to me I
was like wait you had your scanners
poster in the trailer for him to sign
you're that guy huh
yes you are the [__] guy
but also I'm that guy all right like
like I'm
I I'm trying to think you get autographs
from actors that you're working with
on a rare occasion if it's like
something really special I I would for
sure like if for some reason I worked
got to work half a day with Robert
Duvall where he's playing an old
southern judge and he's working four
hours to give a half page monologue
I would for sure shake his hand tell him
uh what a great admirer I am and then
see if he'd sign something
most people I mean I've only asked
people that are really cool Steve Martin
was awesome it was last day on set
um you know Stallone signed my Rambo
lunch box not stolona would have signed
something yeah you have a Rambo lunch
box how old are you that's it
these impressions are so good man you do
Impressions I do some but like I feel
like I'm totally outside no give me one
that you'd like to do
I um I do like a lazy uh Willem Dafoe
where it's just like
Peter Peter Parker he comes into the
room and he thinks he's gonna do
something until I Green Goblin his ass
that's like a six and a half out of ten
I could no I could feel it though I
could feel once you started talking I
could see his like his teeth how he has
that thing going that's the thing with
his mouth
um and then there's uh Gilbert Gottfried
with I can't believe I'm on Michael
[__] Rosenbaum this guy that that is
close I think yes it's great and then um
I think I do who's the guy who Alex
Jones I know who that is uh Infowars the
Infowars guy who's like all right let me
tell you what's going on right now
basically
ah you got Michelle Obama who is an
alien she's an alien oh yeah I know that
guy yeah dude I do like something oh my
God but I used to make SNL audition
tapes nobody would even watch him that
was always my dream to be on SNL same
that was my it was my dream and I did
this pilot for uh Pete Siegel who
directed Tommy Boy and he the co-writer
on that was this guy who wrote on SNL
all the time who was it um for some
reason I forgot his name because like
one of the big writers I'm a big SNL
nerd so he lived right up the street
from here uh but uh Alan zweibel no but
he said to me says if you do this pilot
for us because they fired somebody they
needed me and they well they needed
someone they asked me and I was unsure
if I wanted to do it and he goes if you
do this I'll get you an audition for SNL
he never did it's a big character never
did never even returned my call
okay don't say his name then no say his
name no don't but he wrote Tommy Boy he
I think with Pete Siegel didn't he uh
the writers of Tommy Boy uh Terry
something yep uh Terry Turner oh it's
not Terry Turner Bonnie Turner no maybe
he didn't write on it anyway doesn't
matter uh all right back to you so you
do all these Impressions you're a funny
wolf
Fred Wolf that's it and he was a nice
guy super nice guy but he never did what
he said he would do well he might have
been ashamed like I thought I could
maybe I tried and they said no and now I
don't know how to tell Mikey
honesty is always the best way Fred Wolf
can you just be honest for five seconds
No I um I've done that with folks too
where like I'll I'll say send me your
script I'll read it and I would say
realistically I probably read six out of
every 10 scripts I say I'll read that's
a lot
um I might read one yeah I feel bad
about that but it's also it's also like
you gotta Peg the person like this
happens at the highest levels too it's
not like this goes away if I if I do a
movie with Ethan Hawke and and I'm like
cool if I get your number man would love
to throw you something down the line
yeah sure man hit me up or here's my
email yeah it's not like Ethan Hawke's
going to jump on that and be like I'm
immediately going to read your [__] you
would have to hit him up once every
eight to ten weeks just to check in just
to check in and remind him and and
whatnot yeah like I did you
like you did me sort of not really I
mean I I messaged you and you messaged
me right back
I did hit you back right away and it was
just to kind of
I wanted to make sure you didn't think I
was being uh uh big time
not even yeah or even just the most
basic of what we're talking about which
is just dismissive uh big time or not
people can be dismissive and I never
want someone to feel like I don't but
you don't owe me anything you didn't
know me so you know sometimes like I
want to guess I'm really fond of their
work and sometimes they're not even that
big of an actor but I just love their
working one I'm on sometimes they are
and I do it not all the time but every
once in a while not not often but every
once in a while I will say you know hey
I I want to go through you if you read
this and the podcast if you know me or
you care yeah I'm a big fan and I'd love
to have you on whatever and you know
usually people do it yeah I I think this
stuff is really fun man
inside of you is brought to you by
rocket money I was just telling one of
my friends about rocket money because
you know there's the big strike and all
that stuff the SAG strike and nobody's
working and I was like hey have you
checked your subscriptions
are you uh sure you're not being charged
for other he goes what are you talking
about I go
there's actually this this app it's
really awesome just hear me out rocket
money
and they will take care of all your
subscriptions they'll make sure you're
not getting charged for things that you
don't need anymore like when you when
you watch that one show on Cinemax and
Cinemax still around yeah well it might
I don't know well you accidentally do it
or you subscribe because you just want
to watch one show and then you forget to
unsubscribe and and then you're being
billed and all of a sudden you're like I
just got charged eighty dollars for the
last eight months or something
um I would say the average person has
around 12 subscriptions 12 12.
paid subscriptions
wow that's a lot and then half the time
you don't even know you subscribed to
them if you have no idea just how much
you're spending each month you need
rocket money okay it's this great app
that tracks all of your expenses so you
know exactly where your money is going
80 of people this blew my mind
subscriptions they've forgotten about
eighty percent
uh how many free trials that you do and
you forget about rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place most
people think they're spending eighty
dollars on their subscriptions when in
reality the number is closer to two
hundred dollars when you're signed up
for so many things like streaming
services you used to watch one show or
free trials for delivery you don't use
it's so easy to lose track of what
you're paying for with rocket money you
can easily cancel the ones you don't
want with just the Press of a button no
more long hold times or annoying emails
with customer service rocket money does
all the work for you rocket money can
even negotiate to lower your bills for
you by up to twenty percent all you have
to do is take a picture of your bill and
Rocket money takes care of the rest
rocket money also lets you monitor all
your expenses in one place recommends
custom budgets based on your past
spending and they'll even send you
notifications when you reached your
spending limits with over 3 million
users and Counting rocket money
customers have saved an average of seven
hundred and twenty dollars a year
stop wasting money on things you don't
use cancel your unwanted subscriptions
and manage your money the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com
inside that's rocketmoney.com slash
inside
rocketmoney.com slash inside this
message is sponsored by discover did you
know you could reduce the number of
unwanted calls and emails with online
privacy protection the latest Innovation
from discover discover will help
regularly remove your personal info like
your name and address from 10 popular
people search websites that could sell
your data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection I I know some actors
hate doing press or putting themselves
out there they're like well if I talk
too much about my thing then it doesn't
then it's not special and you you've
kind of shown lifted the veil or
something I'm like I I I don't care I
just it's fun to talk to people and I
like trying to promote what I've done
because we all work hard on our on our
stuff yeah well the thing is with you
it you don't you can't show everything
because even like you joking around now
the reason I messaged you I was watching
Blackbird Yeah by myself
and I love dark [__] I love you know
look at me I can't tell yeah geez Louise
and I was just enamored I was so
look I'm not blowing smoke I I tell
everybody and their mother they've got a
seat if nothing else for your
performance because it's just like you
can't take your eyes and I remember the
first time you open your mouth as uh
Hall Larry Larry Hall the serial killer
right yeah yes
um because something said like in Wiki
it's a suspected serial killer I guess
in the story he's just suspected yeah
and then they figure it out but I
watched his performance and you do
it's it's so it's so unlike you I mean
it's the it's like
well I know you're not a serial killer
but no I'm no I know your mannerisms
your voice I've never heard this so
maybe I have but sell them from an actor
I don't know what you did
but you would be talking to eagerton
right yeah and you'd be having a scene
with him and you go your voice would go
up and it would sort of go down so you
go well yesterday when you were telling
me that you had I was like what is he
doing and I couldn't stop listening to
you you know what I'm talking about the
voice and the and the trash in a little
bit and it was kind of sad and you
didn't want to like him but you kind of
weirdly were starting to and until
things started to unravel I was I was
just blown away I thanks thank you man I
think uh yeah man Taran Edgerton I I
always say I'm like he's a really good
dance partner like sometimes you just
get
blessed with a co-star who you're doing
the majority of your the bulkier work
with and it's like hell yeah uh he's one
of those hell yeah guys
um but I I yeah I try to get Uber
specific and just try to make it honest
and
um and
not you know crazy my brother when I did
the movie I Tonya my brother Matt
um he he was with me on a leg of the
press tour for that or at least he went
to the love doctor New York Premiere
great oh great dope movie just a cool
unexpected yeah like I was like all
right let's go see this and I was like
right it was really well you know the
first time I read that script uh I was I
was in Canada doing a pilot for a
lifetime with a bunch of bunch of cool
people and you know the show was just
okay not something you'd be like I gotta
tell you about the show Emma but the
people were like fun and we're having a
great time up there and I'm feeling so
blessed and spoiled to have this type of
a gig series regular they're paying me
decent even though I've got like nine
lines in the pilot right it's so easy
but but I'm there and I get the offer
for the audition on I Tonya
um because I think Josh Gad had the role
but then he got busy with brano's uh
Train movie The Murder on the order
Express uh murder on the Asian Express
yeah you can't say that
Kenneth Brown a [__] [__] what are
you thinking man
um but I'm like prepping for the
audition I'm reading the script and I'm
laughing my ass off the first time I
read it it feels almost like a
Christopher Guest yeah or something yes
and I'm like a psychotic Christopher
Guest fan
um and then Michael McKeon on oh stop
yeah stop he was on Smallville too he
was great
we've been emailing back if he's like
yes I'm coming I figure it out but go
ahead
um but I a second time I read it I
wasn't laughing it read more like a
David Russell thing where I'm like these
are broken people who are bleeding all
over the place type of thing and and I
was like well that's kind of a good sign
if one made me laugh and the other
almost made me cry just on separate
reads and I'm like this is a cool movie
but then when you're doing it you never
you never know you know you never know
wait why was I talking about because you
were getting to blackbird
Blackbird uh because you're uh oh crazy
people do another crazy so my brother
said to me on that leg of the tour
whatever he was like you know crazy
people my character in Italian Sean
Eckhart he's like crazy people don't
know they're crazy and that's what's so
scary about crazy people because we're
all capable of doing something crazy and
what most of us have but
this idea that you don't know you're
crazy like that's crazy that's scary so
with Larry Hall I just had to really own
that crazy and not be not let the
audience think that I'm cognizant of it
and yet he's emotionally manipulative
for sure and that is what the audience
clues in on a little bit and they're
like okay well I was almost starting to
like this weirdo so long as I don't have
to stand next to him and then uh and
then it's like okay now now I think you
might be messed up oh he's oh he's that
messed up oh I hate this guy kill this
guy yeah and then of course we the
audience feel what Taryn feels an
episode but it was an arc it was just uh
you had to get there it wasn't just and
I always say this it's like you know if
you're gonna play the bad guy yeah
you gotta because bad guys normally
aren't trying to be hated they're you
know they're trying to get what they
want yeah they're trying to you know
they're manipulative they're psychotic
they're uh narcissists or whatever it is
um but yeah that that was incredible I
always think that the best villains in
stories or at least talking movies TV
are the ones who spell out what it is
they're trying to do
they'll actually
give you a verbal peek behind the
curtain as to what what's making this
what the engine of thought is so like
Heath Ledger when he's burning the money
and he's like it's in dark now he's like
it's not about the money and like
uh Christoph Waltz in the opening of and
glorious bastards where he's like let me
let me explain how I see the Jews or
whatever like knowing the Mind behind it
is so
it's such an intimate thing for an
audience to clue in on and it makes you
hate the person even more and it's and I
feel like we did that in in episode four
or five we start to really flirt with
knowing why Larry did what he did and
then it's like oh to this extent oh did
somebody kill this guy yeah yeah
absolutely all the great villains you
get a peak I think yeah it's almost like
they're like this but this is what I
believe Chris Christopher Waltz what
does he hasn't he sound I don't know
I've never done for Chris Wallace I told
no but I know he does this thing where
he talks about Quentin Tarantino that's
it that's it off the cup
um
honestly don't don't inflate it don't be
like oh well I spent four years creating
this character how long from the
Inception or the time you got cast did
you audition for for this character in
Blackbird I did audition you did Zoom
for Dennis Lane
and did you do exactly what you do
pretty much in the in the movie pretty
much that was it was like it
if if what I do in the in the show is a
well done Burger I showed Dennis like
the the medium
yeah and he kind of helped you mold it
and kind of helped you oh yeah he kept
like the voice modulation was tough like
that was all Dennis going hey your voice
is unconsciously getting higher I think
around episode three four here we should
start to have him use it as like a
manipulative tool and um see I knew yeah
I don't think a lot of people when I
bring that up they're like oh cool I was
going crazy with the voice it was just
so in and out and us like almost like
you were singing in a way not singing
But like your character yeah there's a
musicality to it there was something
that yeah it was just weird but did you
did you have tapes to listen to his
voice no there was like 12 seconds of
composite audio on YouTube and some
random local TV documentary that's it
yeah I didn't have any footage Richard
Jewel was different Richard Jewel I had
like 12 to 15 hours of crap they sent me
and I was like dope this is gonna be
easy all I gotta it's like all I gotta
do is get that voice down I already look
like the guy like that that takes care
of that
um but this was more interpretive which
is hard it's not
hard as in not fun not hard isn't hard
digging a ditch is hard teaching in an
inner city school is hard uh but it was
it was trying and not fun to put your
brain where it has to go because there
is the Lawrence Olivier try acting to
your boys thing yeah which I get and we
you know we all appreciate that to
whatever extent
but I'm the type of person where I'm I
don't know that I'm a good enough actor
to fake it I kind of have to think about
uh
and killing in my head while doing the
lines and that's not that's I I know
there are going to be people that think
that's really uncouth and why and how
dare you and what's the point of going
there but it's like that's
what I do to entertain you and make that
character feel believable without
actually
exactly for the love of God it's not
like I'm one of those exactly but but by
the way there are these actors who are
like I'm gonna play a junkie so I gotta
try meth I'm gonna try heroin it's like
no you [__] idiot like you don't have
to do that but but you know what you
could do is befriend somebody who did do
those drugs and get some information
sleep on the floor for five six days and
malnourish yourself and do some of the
stuff that the junkies do and you'll be
good right as Reigns yeah can you have
fun on set while you're doing a part
like this or are you method a thousand
percent you have to have fun so you can
like cut and you're like anyway so uh
the other day yes but it's also not that
I'm not that brilliantly ambidextrous
like if I'm doing a really hard scene
that involves a certain amount of
uh uh mental gymnastics emotionally
verbally whatever I will
go off and I I won't I won't flaunt it
um but I will go off in a corner
in a sound stage with earbuds in and I
will you know listen to the National or
something and and
get myself in the place
[Music]
that guy's always drinking wine isn't he
I think so I saw that uh documentary he
did mistaken for strangers oh
it's great really mistaken for strangers
it's the lead singer of the national
going on tour with his brother and he's
like trying to give his brother a job
but his brother is kind of a a narrative
well and it's like exploring that broken
relationship attempting to find a way to
fix it or yeah yeah
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
better help has been with me for a long
time and I think I know why because this
uh this podcast deals with a lot of
mental health
um people talking about their anxiety
and depressions and uh we're all
imperfect we're all flawed and that's
the beautiful thing about life and
sometimes we get in ruts sometimes
um our path isn't as clear that's in
front of us we're not sure what we're
gonna do we can't find purpose this is
where better help comes in and it's so
important whether you're dealing with
decisions around your career your
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement trusting yourself to make
decisions that align with your values is
like anything the more you practice it
the easier it gets the great thing about
this is the stigma is going away folks
so you know my dad he doesn't go to
therapy and you know I've been talking
to him I'm like listen everybody so many
people do this you're not the only
person who gets in ruts you know when we
lost my sister
um I finally got him into therapy and um
it's just important to know you're not
alone you're just not alone and with
better help you can get your therapist
online if you don't like your therapist
you change it like that it's so easy
it's so much more affordable than
looking up some therapist that you don't
know and going uh yeah and it cost you
so much money to go in there look if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
it's convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire it's so so quick uh and
get matched with a licensed therapist
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge period it's entirely
online so it's convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire it takes seconds and
get Max with a licensed therapist switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge let therapy be your map with
better help visit betterhelp.com inside
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better her help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside let therapy be
your map with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's ten percent
off your first month better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
it's interesting it's funny I have a
relationship with my brother where it's
sort of like you know there's a little
bit of that I won't say much about that
but yeah there it's it's it's difficult
you I want what's I want him to thrive I
want him to do all sure you can't you
can't you can't be a little horse water
yeah you know you just gotta yeah I I
spent years trying to fix my family and
things and I thought what you're this is
crazy what I'm doing this is [__]
crazy if any and I know I'm crazy so
yeah it was just weird it was it's tough
you know it's it's
here's what it is it's not it's not like
the blind leading the blind but it is
the colorblind leading leadership there
you go I am you know what I mean and but
we've all got a version of that word I
used to want to fix people and didn't
realize I needed fixing yeah now that
I'm working on myself and I've done a
pretty good amount of fixing I wouldn't
say 100 but I'm I'm at 45.50 like now I
don't want to fix everybody else because
what I've learned is it's not about
uh an advertisement it's about
attraction you know you attract it you
don't you don't advertise it do you
drink do you do any pot smoking no I did
smoking
I I am I used to I used to do weeds yeah
no I I loved and I'm using the word love
here I loved marijuana and and red wine
and really expensive scotch
and and cheap ass beer and then like
hoppy eight percent were made in a
freaking Asheville North Carolina beer
but I got to a point where I just
realized I was like dude I'm
way too addictive of a person addictive
person like I'll watch four movies in a
movie theater in one day and not blink
click I'm like bring it up wow I will
eat seven slices of pizza and be like
this is normal
okay
so no let's fill it up three times let
me I'm gonna die I want to see my teeth
fall out can I have another Twizzler
yeah
I'm not gonna get the Twizzlers I'm
gonna get the Twizzlers and the Red
Vines all right now you're just you know
you're catering to both audiences or
whatever well it says Michael Jordan
says Republicans and Democrats both buy
Nikes right
A Perfect Analogy perfect eyes crossed
perfect let me ask you this
I I had to cut it out I I have a year
and a half oh sober
on April 26th of this month from
marijuana and alcohol because it uh
it just made me really irresponsible
and I I have a self-hatred that I've
been working on for a long time yeah me
too or something in me it's not even me
I believe in the principle I'm very
spiritual so like I believe in
principalities in your head telling you
you should go kill yourself
um and then you have to combat that with
really good behavior and believe that
either people or God love you in my case
I believe both do yeah uh so you have to
rewrite and feed that narrative
um and alcohol is like opening the
floodgates for the voices so if I was
really drunk it was like man you are
gross and no one will ever want to marry
you and you're a disappointment and you
should kill yourself
and I was like well that's not a tenable
narrative that's not sustainable
um and so yeah I feel way better man I
feel I feel great now well I always say
that like I always tell some of my
friends who you know they they drink too
much they you know and I'm you're their
friend you just [__] say something
you know if you're a good friend yeah
and I do I call people out I just
[__] call them out yeah like I I
drink occasionally there's a there's I'm
70 on that I would say three out of ten
friends I'm like
I'm kind of letting them work through it
or I'm afraid they're not going to
receive it but then the other seven out
of ten I'm like I took my a friend of
mine was doing coke one time in front of
me and offered it to me I've been
offered Coke like six or seven times
never done it because I was afraid
because my heroes Chris Farley I'm not
trying me too oh my God it's mine I
caught them all the time
yeah we can talk but but I I kind of
pulled him aside and was like hey I know
you just booked this pilot and I know
you got some money and and the show's
getting picked up but like this is a
quick way to
[__] on this golden opportunity and I
care about you and I love you that's it
you just kind of
do that out there and then and I would
rat now I would rather them be mad at me
and sever some Tire create some distance
and know that I said something yeah now
that's important to me yeah but it's
tough it is it's tough I think
some people
should not drink
some people should not drink now when I
say some people shouldn't have kids like
that yeah uh yeah listen there are there
are there are unique circumstances in
which people should not be involved in
something yeah I said to this person in
particular I said
when you drink how of all the things
that you regret and most of the things
what percentage happens or bad decisions
when you're doing drugs and you're
drinking when you're snowing they said
probably almost all of them
and I was like well I I don't need to
say anything else
your problems will you'll still have
problems but they'll be easier to deal
with they won't be magnified yeah and
that's uh it's hard also problems but
get problems right and people forget
that like there is a very con
hyper-constructive chain reaction of
events that happen where it's like I'm
drunk uh now I'm kind of I kind of want
to get high now I kind of want to order
food now I just spent 80 bucks on
Postmates for a burger and fries now
we've all done it and then it's like now
I feel like [__] now I'm I have diarrhea
from the burger now I'm gonna be
hungover I have work tomorrow holy [__]
did I buy Imagine Dragon concert tickets
am I going to see Imagine Dragons did I
buy it for the wrong venue did you do
that you son of a [__] that's a true
story
I bought so there's two what is the
place the outdoor venue that's in uh up
in the hiking area the Greek the Greek
yeah I bought tickets for some concert
it was the national actually it wasn't
it wasn't well that's good I bought
Imagine Dragons tickets for the wrong
night
that that's what happened I went to the
Palladium and I it was one of the worst
concerts I've ever been to I hated it
and I don't know why I bought into their
freaking
Illuminati choruses I don't really I'm
not gonna say anything back I just don't
know them I don't know I don't know the
number one song that I know what is the
one song everybody no you you know more
than one I don't know don't act like
names listen if it's music after 2000
fill it in my bones enough to make
masses
welcome to the new age oh yeah to the
new age
radioactive of course you've heard that
I have heard that what about this one
when you feel my heat look into my eyes
it's where my demons hide yeah where my
demons hide or you know the stuff get
too close it's dark inside and now I'm
going into Dave Matthews covering this
song
he wakes up in the morning takes a [__]
cause he ate a Smashburger at 3am he
orders popcorn from Arc Light
as it Uber to his house he's alone I do
I did that I did that I [__] did that
my friend's like you ordered ubered
popcorn oh that's your house that's like
something I swear to God I feel like
that's something Spielberg's family does
right
guys we will not
get her in fear of
geographs and selfies
order this
oh that's amazing let me ask you do you
ever get
was Richard Jewell really the first that
was the first big one before I forget
can I quick do my impression of Bob
Dylan doing Justin Bieber yeah can I
close my eyes yeah okay I mean I wish
you would for a lot of things I'm doing
here
it's uh
is it too late
right
that is the best one
it's the ending of those it's one of my
favorites oh my Lord I also love my
mobster who does I love my mobster who
does Gwen Stefani
where he's like closing him see if you
make me laugh a few times I've been
around that track right but I ain't no
hollaback girl
his [__] is bananas b hey n-a-n-a-s
that's fun that sounded like kind of
like De Niro doing it
you know I went up to De Niro at the SAG
Awards on a commercial break nobody was
bothering him it was probably the best
moment of his life and I I I went up to
him and I just go hey man
I'm Paul Hauser I did this movie I
taught you I'm here for that uh I just
wanted to make sure I said hi to you and
shook your hand the king of comedy is
one of my favorite movies you're amazing
and he just looked at me and went oh I
tell you
and that was it you just made his bitter
beer face and nodded and I walked away
you know I got Star Struck there's this
announcer for the Mets his name was
Ralph keiner no one knows who unless
you're a meds fan but he talked like
this he'd be like
harmless cumulus clouds lingering
overhead fans filing it off the subway a
beautiful day for a ball game that's
Ralph that's Ralph uh Diner was it Bob
Murphy that was Bob Bob Murphy Bob
Murphy and see I'm such a good actor
that I just acted like I knew who that
was but I was repeating Ralph Clan and
then
caused you to say Bob Murphy and I was
like oh Bob Murphy you did it on purpose
so Bob Murphy and he might be
manipulating you this year see you're
jumping into that character again that
Hall character you son of a manipulative
[__]
um so no I didn't mean that about anyway
that's so harsh I know that's right so
Bob you ran into Bobby no no so Bob
Murphy I'm [__] up my own story Bob
Mercer he was like now it's honey dude
now it's honeydew season folks honey do
this and honey do that oh I love it it's
Toyota drives like a dream and so my
uncle met Bob on the street in New York
one day and goes Bob you're Bob Murphy
uh you're the best announcer there is
and there was a long beat
pause and he goes ooh that is so very
kind of you
then he [__] off wow great story huh
that's like the perfect interaction
though I I had a moment like that in New
York City with I'm a huge character
actor fan because I mean I am one um I
saw James rebhorn from the game and
blank check and sent a woman to meet the
parents big character actor he's since
passed but I saw him in New York when I
was like maybe 18 on spring break in the
city I go Miss rebhorn he turns around
like stunned that some 18 year old is
saying his name like and I and he goes
yes I'm Mr rebhorn James red horn shakes
my hand I go you're one of my favorite
actors can I get a picture with you and
then I had one of those wind-up Kodak
cameras and I snapped a photo I don't
even know where it is it might be in my
stages today that you knew his name oh
he made my day but but I made his day
yeah it was I think he was probably
doing something on Broadway or something
like that but yeah it's amazing how many
great actors there are but people don't
know them by name I know you know and
like I you know it's funny because you
know I want to get back to the question
about Richard Jewell yeah well not
necessarily Richard Jewell but sort of
but what was I gonna but if we could
talk about me
a lot well that's what the podcast is oh
thank God because I was starting to
worry because that inside I don't want
us to have fun actually having a
conversation with two people are are we
not having fun no we are I'm said that's
my joke
how dare we detour and talk about my
career when we're no I'm actually having
legitimate fun just talking we will and
we'll continue that I just want to know
if you get like you know you said like
Star Struck like that character actor
but like you know I'm thinking Richard
Jules at the first time you worked with
such enormous actress because there was
a lot of them in that and you're
directed by Clint Eastwood do you get
star struck by these big guys does it
kind of make you nervous in the first
few takes does it is this or are you
kind of like confident and let's do my
thing
there was a there was some sort of turn
that happened with Blackbird where I I
think my experience on five and a half
months of blackbird with Taryn and
Dennis that kind of broke me of the
star struckness because I just I just I
like a lot of people I have in posture
syndrome me too
um that's you know that's a normal thing
and for those listening I use that term
all the time and people are always
asking me what does that mean imposter
syndrome is essentially like akin to uh
you are in a position of some kind be it
a marriage be it a job whatever and you
feel that you don't deserve it or that
you kind of stumbled into it rather than
earned it
um and that you're gonna maybe be found
out by these people in this circumstance
so
so I I you know on I Tonya I had a day
where Margot
uh is skating and I'm supposed to be
talking to her and she kind of
bad-mouths me in this ice rink and I
what I knew I wasn't getting the face I
wanted I wasn't able to like I wasn't
eliciting enough pain and it was because
she and I had hung out at that point and
talked and like we're buddy buddy and I
was like I kind of need something from
her that will make me
feel like crap and I can really live in
it
and so apparently the mirror wasn't
enough
um come on but I went up to her and I
said can you tell me I'm inadequate and
she's like what do you mean like in the
like say that in the scene and I was
like no no can you Margo tell me Paul
you're inadequate
and she's like oh like she looked
disgusted and she's like I don't want to
say that and I was like I know I need it
though
she looked to me she goes okay and she
literally takes like a beat like a
thoughtful beat and then looks up at me
and goes
Paul you're inadequate
and I felt it and I was like Oh and it
did hurt and I was like good I'm glad I
did that then she went away and we did
the take and the take was really good
and she like skated up to me afterwards
I was like I'm sorry I didn't mean that
I was like no I know I just I because I
I I feel that um and then after
Blackbird you know Dennis and Taryn
treated me like a co-conspirator like a
true equal and that sort of
feeling really rubbed off on me and made
me feel like I had a place here and that
I yeah I could be a leader on and Offset
you belong yeah yeah I really did
um and and so after that I would say
going into 2022 I I don't really get
Star Struck anymore I was a little
nervous I just worked on Matt Damon and
Casey Affleck on a Doug Lyman movie
um I have a few more days on that what's
it called it's called the instigators
but you Matt Damon you were a little bit
like Damon well Damon Inc I think
Casey's one of our best actors working
and and I think Matt is too but in a
different way in the sense of like
you know Matt Damon will make you bust
the gut in some comedy thing and then a
minute later he's
commanding a Ridley Scott film or he's
in a Chris Nolan movie so I I was a
little nervous going into that because
I'm just like these are guys I really
respect and I want to bring it I want to
bring it right I understand I'm the
seventh man you know I'm number two or
three on the bench and this is Jordan
and Pippen or whatever but I'm like if
you put me in for three minutes you
better believe I'm gonna get you two
rebounds and I'm gonna score at least
once I'm gonna try to block somebody oh
yeah I'm gonna make that three minutes
count that's a good way to think so
that's just my thing going in now is
like I do have a lot of pressure on
myself to be great right and what I
learned most often is like you don't
have to put yourself through some
mental rigmarole for every single role
right like some stuff you know you know
how to do and you just gotta do it and
not question it and pretend you're gonna
get the peripheral Oscar or something
yeah but we both we both worked for
Clint Eastwood I just had one big scene
in a movie yeah what was your scene I
haven't seen that it's it's no one saw
it it's called Midnight in the Garden
good and evil I had like a scene where
they cross-examined me but it you know
it's a lot of great actors Jack Thompson
and you know Spacey and yeah kusak and
I'm being cross-examined it's my first
role in a movie and you know I I'm
playing a character and it was just holy
[__] but like for you and I remember how
I felt it's like look at this this is my
first movie were you like when he's like
all right Paul
here's what I want you to do on this one
if you could show a little a little bit
more vulnerability but don't give it to
them don't make them see it try to make
it like it's not you know it's a private
moment that's uh that's that's really
good I mean were you like um in the
beginning like oh my God Clint
Eastwood's directing me it was um no
because he would never say that many
words
[Laughter]
glint's whole thing was minimalism and
exactitude which you know I appreciate
Spike Lee does the same thing so it
didn't have a lot of notes
no the only notes he ever gave me uh
were
uh speed like pacing like Paul Thomas
Anderson made fun of Phil Hoffman on the
set of Magnolia he's like he's like this
is how I get up and look at a framed
photo on a table he walks up takes three
seconds to walk up looks at it goes hmm
and sets it back down it's all of eight
seconds he goes here's how Phil does it
and then he walks up and he's like
looking around for like 30 seconds
can I get to the photo discovers the
photo so it has like a moment where he's
about to cry like I I kind of got caught
doing that on Richard Jewel a couple
times and and Clint would walk up to me
and go ah it needs a little more uh
skipped my Lou Skip to My left Pace it
up and I'd be like oh man the boss is
right and by the way I would say eight
or nine out of ten times he was right
and I was milking something uh it mostly
unconsciously and then once in a while
I'd be like uh this like
this is a big this is a big moment I
think the editor should find the pacing
I need to honor this moment and really
feel the breadth of it and make sure
that there's an origin to the conclusion
because some scenes it's like you should
have seen the original screenplay
Billy Ray wrote a great script no shock
there he's Billy Ray but they had me
Richard Jewell crying like three or four
times in the movie and I was like I
can't
we can't have me crying that many times
it's gonna take all the power out of it
and you know doesn't it make more sense
to let it build I'll get choked up
uh when my mom starts getting emotional
because I'm mad that this is affecting
my mother you're right you're had a
little thing there but then we saved it
for the end and we really let the the
damn kind of burst and break in the
diner scene with me and me and Rockwell
yeah and that was the right move yeah
that was the right move because you
don't want to be like uh uh like a
schlub guy schlubbed character you know
you don't wanna you wanna have a little
bit like you want to have some Integrity
right you want him to have some well and
I don't I don't know that
I don't know that Integrity is congruent
to not crying but I think I think for
for me for an audience if we're seeing
it happen over and over it's like it's
not special sexuality is the same thing
in movies where like you know I got beat
over the head with so much sexual
imagery and cocaine and buffoonery and
Wolf of Wall Street it actually made me
not really appreciate it watching that
film I'm kind of like this might be one
of my least favorites Wow movies yeah
you're right it's it's it's a balance
and like they always say as an actor you
know people try not to cry in the real
world of course they don't want to cry
yeah so you know we're not always crying
we're always stopping ourselves from
crying like stop it stop it breathe
close your eyes close your eyes you
don't want water to come out [__] like
that or you're not or you're not even
thinking about the tears because you're
in the moment and then the tears will do
what they will and that's usually when
they fall down in full-on drops they
don't drizzle they just bam yeah because
you're too busy thinking and feeling
that you're not cognizant yeah you know
we're I the Imposter syndrome because I
I I've always had it I always think that
I'm not worthy I'm not they're gonna
find me out same [__] I've always had it
and it makes sense because I look back
at my childhood now when you look back
in your childhood does your child did
you have a happy childhood did you have
like I know you went to like uh uh
a private school I did we went to by the
way we were not well to do we had we had
shits for money
um we lived in a really really dangerous
neighborhood in Saginaw Michigan called
North Bond Street and we had we had like
a police dog shot by a bank robber in
our backyard on Thanksgiving night we
had our house broken into our car broken
into we knew gang members and people
that were like selling drugs out of
their house like my dad was a Lutheran
Pastor so
Monday through Saturday it was kind of
like the wire and then on Sundays it's
like The Andy Griffith Show where I'm
like wearing suspenders in a bow tie
eating donut holes talking to senior
citizens in Sunday School
you know that's what made me the actor
and dude I am I've seen it all well to
some to some extent yeah
um
so so I kind of
yeah I just I I I want to answer your
question I don't want to just
pontificate about my [__] no no
paints a picture the question was um
growing up what was it I had a good
childhood
um but you know it's uh a constancy of
the dark and light Duality and and
juxtaposition so you know you go to a
Lutheran School
and everything is you know sunshiny
Jesus but there's also like the the
cracks and the foundation and even as a
kid I was keenly aware of uh I had a
high I didn't have a high IQ but I had a
high EQ which a lot of creatives do and
so you know I would see like there's
this great story of me and one of my
closer long time friends this guy Evan
Chisholm where Evan and I in first grade
so I'm like seven years old
we're sitting next to each other doing
our workbooks where you're just writing
O's and and trying a curse of f out or
whatever the thing is
and I noticed he was like very dutiful
and very liked his studies to you like I
could see him pressuring himself
and so I just for my own Amusement
started hurrying through my workbook as
if I was finishing each thing while
sitting next to him and I saw him kind
of look over and him try to like hurry
up like seeing the competitive nature
and then like after I I pretended to
have finished the whole workbook or
whatever in like two minutes and then he
just slams us down and starts crying and
puts his head in his hands and you know
it's it's a horrific story to some
degree because I feel bad that like
clearly my friend Evan in youth or
throughout his life did have a
Competitive Edge and that was something
emotionally charged for him wow but in
that moment how does a seven-year-old
know to play that sort of Mark's brother
adjacent prank to another kid right so
clearly you know there was there were
things like that or my second grade
teacher Mrs rathke she'd she was having
hip surgery at the time and she's
teaching second grade and she's not
getting paid [__]
and uh and there were moments where my
buddy Josh Britton would be pulling on
her dress saying teacher teacher teacher
and I remember her turning around going
sit down and shut up
dying laughing at the dark comedy of it
all but also being terrified like there
are all these moments etched in my
memory and it's always a duality of
light and dark and looking back like I'm
still a self-professed Christian person
I'm still a big Jesus guy uh
but I like there's so many things that
were fundamentally wrong about how
the the church views women or different
races or just interprets some text that
they think they have the corner marketed
on intellectual thought it's like what
the [__] man Evolution what's that ever
hear of evolution uh we we evolve listen
the Bible itself says let's think about
this on the way here it's funny that
it's actually coming up in our convo uh
organically the the Bible has a moment
where they say that in heaven or to God
a day is like a thousand years and a
thousand years is like a day
and so it's like it's it's trying to say
it's trying to be evocative of the great
mystery of like you you don't know you
don't know
and that and that is of course if this
is true what else is true so you tell
that to a Christian though a devout
Christian and they go okay well if a
thousand years it's like a day and Days
Like A Thousand Years
that must mean that the world's only
been around that must mean that it only
took seven days or seven thousand days
to make the Earth it's one of those two
through seven days or seven thousand
then right it's like
I go back to Brian Regan uh the big
yellow one is the sun the yellow one is
the Sun and it's like a kid doing his uh
science fair project with all the foam
balls as the planets you know it's just
and I feel bad for those folks they're
not they're not bad people but they sure
as hell have a huge effect
on the world and to stay undereducated
and to not
crack open this thing you hold dearly
and and go on the journey it's really
damaging so I I I think my dark humor
and my my proclivity for comedy and
drama comes from a childhood that
definitely was exposed to both in its in
its most pure and gritty forms you know
were you popular in high school were you
picked on were you what was it I was I
was popular my whole life but I was
picked on for being fat uh in
throughout my life like being a pudgy
kid or being how did that affect you it
obviously affected oh I mean you know
you you're you're not you're not getting
invited to certain parties you're not
getting laid nor did I want to I was
busy playing video games and drinking
Slurpees and and studying Saturday Night
Live I didn't I didn't care I didn't
need to have sex I had you know the
internet
um wait a minute wait a minute
if you had a choice
I mean then it's the hottest chick in
the high school came up and was like hey
come out with me and
it would in retrospect it would have
changed my personality I think because
you're still growing so much then that I
think I would have had different
yeah would it have been nice yeah sure a
young younger little or Paul I wish he
would have had a little little extra
sugar in his coffee or whatever but
the idea is my sort of sheltered
virgin mindset at that time is what made
me the actor I am and made me go on this
journey to become who I am I like who I
am now I haven't always so I don't I
don't like the idea of me getting laid
and then suddenly like well who cares
about theater
who cares about SNL or my Creator be
inside of another human being on a
Saturday night why am I why am I worse
no you just went full Farley I did yeah
here's what I want to tell you just let
the boy sleep in your bed he's a good
boy he said he'd wash the sheets please
don't make me wash the teeth wash your
own damn sheets but you're missing the
best part when he does those Impressions
yeah that
after his sentence ago he's a good he's
a good boy will you let him watch
it's like throwing salt on a chocolate
chip cookie man it Farley would do stuff
like that nobody's funnier nobody has
ever made me laugh that hard and he I
thought he was a really good actor he
could have done a lot of other things
like that moment in Tommy Boy in the
boat I was like yeah I mean just being
vulnerable and I haven't told the story
I'm not gonna tell you but I'll tell you
as you know as buddies all the time but
like I uh I had I I hung out with him a
few times Kevin his brother asked me to
be in the documentary I told the story
of the first time I met him and it was
just oh that's right I saw you in the
document it was I am Chris Farley yeah I
think it was I am Chris yeah yeah but
anyway yeah I I I I had Bob Odenkirk on
here who wrote All the I know uh you
know those sketches uh Matt Foley Bob's
the one who's very vehemently against
the um Chippendale sketch he's very
vocal yeah he said it on here he was
just like yeah I didn't like how you
know it was just
um fatty fall down yeah yeah
and it's funny because
yeah I don't know how that that is I've
never been like overweight but I was
always really small I was the smallest
kid in my high school I actually started
you're so tall I grew when I graduated
high school on my license I figured I
could find it somewhere I think it says
five three and what yeah and then I grew
like nine inches in between high school
and college
you twins you totally twins did you went
from DeVito to shorts I did but like it
was it was hard it was hard for me I
cried I cried for being picked on and
being small and like so I got made fun
of two for B when I moved to LA for
being a devout like Christian like I
would be in church at Sherman Oaks
Lutheran off Ventura Boulevard behind
the Mel's Diner every Sunday and if I
was at a bonfire and we were all stoned
I'd be like trying to talk about
something spiritual and everybody around
me is like oh there's no God or if there
was a God why would he let bad things
happen then I'm like yeah yeah yeah but
uh and
and then they're like wanna know like
every God be God like aren't religions
all the same basically and I'm just like
well there's there's some congruency but
it just becomes like a really
tough thing but you know what that was
also me not being sober minded the Bible
talks about sobriety
a lot a weird amount
and it says to be sober minded and and I
think now that I am not only have I
kicked some of those uh demons trying to
take over my narrative in my head but
I've also
clarified what it is I believe rather
than parroted
some sort of uh religious mimicry that
that's been passed down almost as a
generational curse more than a blessing
uh I've well said that was well said uh
I will ask you this one question and
then we're gonna go into [__] talking
Paul Walter Hauser these are my it's
fast rapid fire it's my patrons who I
love but first i'm obviously everybody
knows you'll won the Golden Globe
everybody loves the speech it's funny
the plastic joke though whatever the I
mean it just it's it's guys like you
that you see up there and you're like
this is a real dude this is a real guy
he's not just not moving you know and
he's just trying to be look his greatest
and handsome like you were just real you
were just up there you looked handsome
but you were not trying you were just it
just felt like a regular being a human
being is what I'm saying yeah and um
sorry that will forever remind me of
Clifford where Charles Grodin says to
Martin Short can you just be a human boy
and Martin Short looks at like this
I totally can't do it have you seen that
movie no oh my God have you Ryan no
wasn't it ranked in one of the worst
movies in history
Yeah by a bunch of recalcitrant adults
you're gonna make me watch it aren't you
if you want to have a good laugh and
love Martin Short and Charles Grodin and
Dabney Coleman and Mary steenberg and
more than you already do I love them
all right keep talking keep talking
about how I gave
a really humble I'm not even I'm not
even I'm gonna talk about that I want to
talk about
I mean you know a lot of people will say
ah it's just an award I don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] I don't give a
[__] but to me it's like it's saying hey
what I'm doing
I'm getting recognition from resonates
it resonates it's just [__] to say
you don't give a [__] unless you've won
10. you know but it's just I I give a
[__] of course yeah I mean I would be
lying to say I don't care
um I think for me that moment was like
uh wow I'm I'm in this conversation that
I've been wanting to be in uh not
because I need to
not because I need to go to the Chateau
Marmot and sip drinks with Adrian Brody
or something it's like that's not why I
need to be in the conversation I need
and want to be in the conversation to
prove that I'm I'm able to do great work
and just like an athlete I want to win
championships this is my sport
I do not show up just because it's fun I
show up because I'm trying to absolutely
murder it
um even in a guest star on a sitcom I'm
only there to murder it and to try to uh
build up and love the people who do the
show every single day Elevate the show
them out so that's that's my mindset
with that um but you know a lot of
people are like well the hollywoodform
press Association sucks and the Globes
don't matter well it was it was nice
it's nice having that moment I enjoyed
it and the Critics Choice means even
more the critics are watching so much
stuff dude they're so they have watch
fatigue and then uh yeah the SAG Awards
I didn't win but I got nominated I lost
to Sam Elliott who's a legend who I love
I want to thank Paul Walter Hauser I
just want to say um
I'm tired of playing Ranch hands yeah
let me be in your next Enron film can I
see this mustache
I love that I do too look can you
imagine I loved him I loved him since
the Solomon mask everybody everybody
said they were so mad when he said that
he didn't like
what was that movie he said he didn't
get the Western with Benedict oh power
of the dog I didn't see it he a good
movie by the way I really liked it
um and the acting holy Kirsten Dunst is
an absolute Killer really she might have
given my the best performance of the
film and it's full of good performances
but
that film deals with like um the the um
how homosexuality was like treated back
in the day in that time and in that
geographical areas and and it's handled
really delicately and beautifully I I
really I love that yeah but it was
interesting because Sam Elliott was like
what is the kind of like the hell is
this this doesn't feel like a cowboy
movie or I don't I don't really like
this thing and people were like how dare
Sam Elliott say that it's like dude that
guy's a hundred years old he's made a
billion of these westerns yeah like not
about it it's not like he's picking
outside saying like I I I disagree with
his sentiment but like it's just funny
how like any time we have any chance to
pick on somebody out it's like
everybody's out you just say something
out can by the way can I tell you why we
do that as a culture it's because
there's no accountability at the Top If
people are actually held accountable and
there was real Justice outside of Street
Justice which street Justice is now of
course the information Super Highway
people wouldn't be that pissed off but
we're all pissed off and outraged by
Banks being uh you know uh bailed out
and politicians on both sides of the
aisle doing whatever the hell they want
and promising everything with nothing in
return so for us it's like well you know
what I'm going to be a well what is that
where you can make a citizen's arrest
it's a bunch of people going I'm gonna
make 80 citizens arrests on all these
people who do misdemeanors but I'm going
to treat them like felonies because F
you you have the life I want and I'm
gonna throw you in it's the small it's
like the such a small percentage of
people that dictate what everybody else
it's like an electoral college it's like
[__] we listening to these
bananas for I I hate it it's like
there's some things that yes you should
be you said something like that and did
something [__] off and there are
companies that are being paid to
strategically stir the pot and they have
these bot things that are just like
you you look at them and it's like we
have I have five followers and I follow
1100 people and I signed up for Twitter
yesterday and now I'm bashing this one
person it's like dude
that's not people have jobs people are
doing [__] what if they what if they cut
that asset a way that you couldn't say
hateful things to anybody on the
internet on on Instagram Twitter and
Facebook there was some kind of
algorithm or whatever it is
I mean would that be amazing if someone
could say so when you type something
like this [__] no but you could
only say
opinions but you can't call someone a
whatever
that's too hard I don't think I don't
think they would allow freedom of speech
they won't allow that in the natural in
the sense of like we're gonna make
something finite they will only allow
that to be an assumed part of discourse
where you can't say this word don't talk
about that thing it's almost like the
flow of traffic we don't have a speed
limit sign but you better go to the flow
of the traffic because these are the
[__] cars you know on the AI there's
the AI app what's it called where you
could it could tell a story oh yeah
that's bizarre that's berserk and it's
yeah it's it's there's gonna be no
writers left it's gonna write it's you
know
and it's ridiculous but you can't type
in like murder
it will say no it won't let you do it
so that's why I was thinking about that
if that app won't let you do things like
that won't talk about her you know
whatever vagina
I don't know why yeah vagina
you could say vagina no it's it's the
idea of uh it depends what you're
talking about sure it um but it
it is the kind of thing where you you
can only police so much and then what
you're doing is you're really it's
almost like bad parenting
where we're kind of like we're telling
one kid like don't do this then the
other kid does it and then it's like
okay well you guys can't do this other
thing and then the other kid does it
it's like it's so unbalanced that it
makes more sense to loosen the reins
than to tighten them because now you're
just making people angrier yeah and
anger is going to compound and compress
amidst Automation and no job creation
and all the absurdities that and what
we're talking about isn't even political
no I'm just saying this is not anyway
all right [__] talking with Paul Walter
Hauser let's do it uh these are the
patrons uh thank you go to patreon.com
uh inside of you and thank you for all
the love and become a patron if you want
to support the show Megan K says how do
you prepare to get in the headspace well
we've already talked about that like
Larry Hall and the performance was
mesmerizing but getting in the headspace
is just all about I am going to own this
posture these thoughts uh and I'm going
to be free as a child to play so that
I'm making everyone happy and saying the
lines but I'm also being malleable to
creative thought you memorize lines fast
yes very fast not very not like soap
opera fast but I I if somebody gave you
a monologue and said I needed you to do
this in two hours oh 100 if someone gave
me a monologue and it was two pages long
I could have it done in maybe an hour
on the spot with all the nervousness
going on on set yeah I'm not saying I'm
gonna win an award with said monologue
yell at me Jesus memorize it Leanne
before accepting your role in Cobra Kai
were you a fan of The Karate Kid series
I was a fan not a mega fan I'd only seen
the first one I haven't seen two and
three but I was a mega fan of what they
did in season one of Cobra Kai when I
got the offer I'm like cover Kai That's
a Karate Kid sequel on YouTube like it
didn't sound good and then I watched and
I'm like this is way better than anyone
even understands and uh and I jumped on
board and had a blind and they kept
bringing it back
kept bringing me back I improvised a lot
and and did a lot of physicality I love
what season is it stuff
what season is what yeah Cobra Kai
I think we're doing the sixth and final
are you in that I'm in two four and five
I'm not I I don't know what's going on
would you go back if they asked you uh
under the right circumstances in the
right circumstances
um Jessica B
what gets you motivated in life uh
motivated in life uh
trying to figure out how to answer that
I get this is rapid fire so I'll just
say whatever you can always what what
gets me motivated is uh I go on YouTube
and I watch interviews with politicians
and uh and um
I watch politicians I watch comedians I
watch actors I watch musicians
I watch uh you know foreign bankers like
I just economists I try to sponge up
what's going on in the world from from
some sort of bird's eye view and I
sponge up what I love about the world so
I look at its Brokenness and then I look
at the greatness in it and then I try to
contribute in some way both in in how I
treat said world and and what I do
creatively
um but nothing will ever help me
exercise more than run the jewels and
Kendrick Lamar and nothing will ever
help me love people better than drinking
a lot of coffee and uh reading the Bible
and meditating and going to uh my
program to stay sober
run the jewels I agree that gets me
pumped I adore them
I just love your answers off the cuff
you just sped through that
Danny
well we talked about Clint Eastwood so
forget that sorry yeah no more East ones
I will say about Eastwood one of my
greatest memories is I was trying to
open a wine bottle at um this restaurant
in Atlanta I couldn't get it open and he
goes give it here he takes wine ball
puts it between his legs he said he's a
he's strong but he's a thin you know
little guy too hope he he would hate me
saying that I bet he pulls out a Swiss
army knife Jabs stabs it into the Cork
and starts doing the old school twist
with a Swiss army knife I mean it was
like trying to get milk from a dying cow
it was and two to three minutes into it
I'm like is I am is he gonna seize up am
I gonna am I going to kill this man with
trying to open my bottle so I'm about to
stop him and he rips the cork open and
opens it and pours it for me I was like
that was that was one of the coolest
moments ever is what'd you think I
wasn't gonna make it you think I can't
open a bottle of wine yeah
directed 800 movies I was Bronco [__]
Billy you piece of [__] it's about to
direct number 40. the movie's called
juror number two Tony Collette Nick Holt
oh my gosh you know what's funny and I
remember on set he uh he got pissed I
have never seen him pissed I've only
been on set with him probably a week or
so but
he got mad at Spacey Spacey was going
he's like listen was Spacey choking a
young man no straddling him oh my God
this is was that was that it no what
that's not what happened Kevin no he's
only he's only been accused of that kind
of thing 20 to 30 times there's no way
he's done it
there's no validity what do you see now
you're turning it like I don't believe
it no no no no I love [__] on Kevin
space no but he goes
you said something like Clint listen uh
do you want me to walk around this uh
and then whatever you say he was doing
this thing am I supposed to do this
thing your way or is it yes listen to me
no I don't care you know I'm gonna do
this this way and Clinton this is how I
talk Clint responds to him he goes he
goes yeah you know you could do that if
he goes well no what what is it you want
me to do
and I forgot but all of a sudden Clint
just goes God damn it Kevin or whatever
you want to do do it [__] he walked away
and he just for a moment he snapped and
it was awesome I love that and I asked
him on set I go in the movie in the line
of fire and he looked at me and goes all
right where's this going I go you have a
line where you're talking to Malkovich
and you say on the phone
you have a rendezvous with my [__]
[__]
and he looks at me and goes yeah and I
go was that improvised it seems so real
yes I might have added order to yeah
that's so good I was Rockwell and I got
to be on his uh private plane or
whatever his jet like with him yeah we
got to do it twice with him from uh
Atlanta how many naps did he take none
he stayed awake reading the newspaper he
ate a salad you know had a glass of wine
or something we we sat with him and
watched his movies in front of him and
he would do like audio commentary oh
peripherally watching it with us
I remember that we had no makeup he'd
see my goddamn wrinkles too much dude
I'm telling you I think we watched
Deathpool or something Deadpool Deadpool
Deadpool something Jim Carrey no it
wasn't that one then it was something
else maybe that wasn't Deadpool but he
no you're right that is a little gym but
he was laughing at half the movie and
he's like so embarrassing like making
fun of it like Mystery Science Theater
3000. don't you wish you had that moment
recorded oh yeah yeah he really
whispered talks though you got to listen
like I'm intimidating I would lean in
eighty percent of the time he and I were
talking because I I didn't want to it's
Eastwood like you're dying to know what
he's saying and you don't want to just
smile and Nod like a you know what the
key is no one does this but if I'm gonna
if you're at a loud concert you know how
people yell in your ear when they're
trying to say something and you're like
[__] dude don't yell in my ear like
everybody does that it's so easy no
you take your ears like this just like
this go hey and you can talk like this
and they'll hear you everything you say
if you just if they do if you talk like
this and you have your ears like that
and they're talking to you I'm not
kidding I just I know I believe you but
I just I wouldn't do that to Clinton
what's that Clint
I said
can hear me now you son of a [__]
dude I'm telling you I would love
nothing more than to be at that Imagine
Dragons concert and be like can you hear
me now and they're like no let's leave
because it doesn't work
uh this has been an absolute treat I
don't want to keep you here any longer
it's up to you I'm having a good time no
it's so fun I mean it's just like you
could tell it's like it's I never even
look at this it's just but it's just so
easy you're just like I don't even if
we're if we're closing out let's talk
Farley for a few minutes right talk
Farley all right so yeah so I met him uh
his brothers were on this show it was
the worst ranked show in history it was
like ranked 130 out of 131 or 129. and
uh it was terrible it was it was a Tom
Arnold show love Tom show was terrible
it was me Ed McMahon but I had like I
was like six you know Tom was Chris's
sponsor yes yeah I love Tom his son's
Godfather and but the show was just bad
but we had a lot of fun and so I'm doing
a scene and I'm saying my lines and
people are starting to really laugh and
I'm like my lines aren't funny there I
don't know why they're they can't it
can't be at me
and I turn and Farley law is is there
he's in a suit baggy suit and he just
kind of it's waving into the eye she's
like oh three camera yeah yeah four
camera I think and he goes he goes how
are you all right how are you good to
see you good all right that looks good
on you and and good good all right
and I'm
numb and I go I have to do something
that he'll remember me but I I just half
this is my hero and I go
hey everybody
look it's the big fat guy taking all the
attention away from the skinny Punk
who's trying to have a career
and he goes looks at me and goes
and he runs over he picks me up over his
shoulder starts smacking my ass runs
through the studio everybody's smacking
my ass we go in the golf cart afterwards
up through Universal the psycho house we
have beers I go back to his house to
have some drinks what was this 95 96
seven or something oh that was right
before right before because I remember
this the horrible part is his brothers
we came in for a moment with Tom Arnold
he had a a in his an egg meeting in his
dressing room and he says get in here I
go I don't really have a drink get the
[__] in here you're coming in here come
on buddy get in here it was me Johnny
and Kevin Farley and I remember Kevin
just going
you know Tom looks at him we're talking
he goes buddy all right your brother's
he's gonna die you know your brothers
you just can't I can't maintain that you
know and Kevin's like yeah I know
Johnny's just like they're distraught
they're like you know we don't know what
to do
and then I I feel like it wasn't long it
might have been a week or two it seems
like less
that all of a sudden
Kevin starts running across the stage
and I'm sitting on the couch waiting
just looking at my lines or taking a nap
or so I see him I know Kevin are you all
right he looked frantic he goes my
brother just died
and
everybody was just like what just
I still I just feel it right now I feel
that moment
heartbroken heartbroken for them and
heartbroken for Chris and heartbroken
for so many people that just
loved him just people felt like they
knew him you know he just made everybody
feel good and made everybody laugh and
it was just it was it was
you know I went from a great moment to a
tragic moment but I remember I'll never
forget when Kevin ran off stage it was I
don't really tell that have I told that
story never told that story yeah it was
it was heartbreaking heartbreaking
um
there is something
you can there's some stuff you can teach
with comedy you can teach some comedy
you know uh you watch Rose Byrne in
Bridesmaids and it's like she's being
very funny but she has to be a different
kind of funny you know opposite all
these crazy women
the characters I mean um
and then there's comedy you can't teach
there's something
that's in your blood and your bones that
is
almost like a nationality
does that make sense yep I think Chris
had some
nationality of Comedy that uh you know I
believe in God everybody else you know
says showing your blank here but I
really believe that God gave Chris like
the nationality of Comedy
and he was always destined to use that
to bring light into the world but you
know if I believe in God you know I I
believe in the other guy I believe in
the other side of it and I think
there's something that that really
Darkness loves Darkness Darkness and
liquid
and Chris Chris got extinguished too
early
um
and it's awful it's absolutely yeah
awful because
um
because he there was so much more
waiting for Chris there was there was a
wife there were kids there were
Academy Award nominatable opportunities
there were non-profits there were all
these things that were there the sky was
the limit but it's what you said earlier
it's that imposter syndrome it's yet not
loving yourself it's like I'm the fact I
know no women love me I have to make
them laugh that's my currency
I had this this way and there was like
that sadness like I gotta be the party I
gotta be I I who knows it's just it's
real and to anybody listening I would
just say or watching just for a
refresher between I think I speak for
both of us like you you don't have to be
anything to anybody other than kind and
accountable
you don't have to be anything never
believe you have to be anything other
than kind and accountable those are the
Baseline more than that that's your
decision and um if you don't want to be
somebody's uh butt of their joke don't
be
fight it
because because Something's Gonna try to
Define you and it will hurt you and it
will erode and eat away at you
um and your Soul's enamel deserves to be
preserved so please make a decision that
is healthy and best for you not other
people
that's what this show's about a lot a
lot we talk about that a lot choked up a
little bit
um this has been awesome dude yeah this
is dude anytime this is something say
that again anytime no matter how big you
get because I'm not saying this I you're
one of those guys I know will win an
Oscar no I don't laugh no no no you're
that good you're that good but you're
also don't ever lose this
you know no it seems like you won't
you're just a grounded dude yeah I I
also I think I have
people in my life that there you go like
not all my friends are Uber successful
like my friends are my friends because
they're my friends yes I mostly have
non-celebratory is that what you say
non-celebrity friends or whatever uh
most of my friends my friend of 38 years
uh grew up down the street from me he
was the popular kid and Tom and you know
so anyway let me qualify that too before
I get uh buried for what I just said I
meant successful in the sense of our
industry in a life they are many of them
are very successful I just mean what we
do right um and in turn I think I'm very
good at what I do but I'm very
unsuccessful in many other facets of
life right that's probably why I put so
much effort into this thing because I
know I know I can do it yeah yeah stop
working stop working I have two children
I better work more
they pay character actors but they don't
always pay us out whoa
kinda gotta do a lot of work right
you're you're doing just ladies and
gentlemen for all those who think that
they got a hustle and bustle the answer
is you do the world's falling apart the
economy is economy and you're gonna end
up on a steady diet of government cheese
Thrice divorced and living in a van now
by the river
thank you thank you
I don't know what else if you didn't
love that interview you don't love
interviews
I think that was like a great interview
he's uh interesting uh
funny
just uh adorable Paul you're adorable
remember after it was like you guys were
finishing up a sleepover you're like
exchanging action figures
yeah yeah that's what we used to do but
uh it did it felt like I was just
hanging out with the bud yeah and that's
how he made me feel he hung out for a
while after yeah so thanks uh
thanks for listening folks I appreciate
it if you enjoyed it again follow the
podcast write a review tell us what you
think we'd love to hear from you uh if
you want to join patreon and help the
podcast which we need your help more
than anything without my patrons I
wouldn't be here patreon.com inside of
you uh the inside of your online store
has a bunch of cool stuff like the the
ship key signed and tumblers and sip ups
and pictures and all the scripts and all
that stuff and you could also get cool
stuff there so that's it uh you can
listen to the intro if you want to find
out other information about where I'll
be I'm also on the Cameo and all that uh
all right we're gonna give the shout
outs thank you Paul for being on the
podcast we love you man you are awesome
I hope you come back here are the shout
outs Nancy D Leah and Kristen little
Lisa you Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico P
Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C Joshua D
Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle b l
Don Supremo you know it's El Dan some
promo because it's Dan
Santiago M the wonderful statue of uh
Lex is is right there he's amazing Chad
W Liam P Maddie s Belinda n Dave Hull
Dave Hall I love Dave
uh shilaji Brad d Ray a harada I hope
the little baby is doing well Tabitha
tea Tom and Talia M Betsy D where are
you Betsy D I don't even talk to you
anymore I missed Betsy D and Angel M and
Rhiannon C Corey Kate Dev Nixon Michelle
okay okay Jeremy C Brandy D Joey M
Eugene and Leah yes
[Music]
Mel yes Christine yes tell me if this
sounds sexy or creepy ready this is
called sexier creepy with Elena Michael
no it'll close my eyes
creepy okay
Shane r
a little sexier thank you
creepy
Amanda R
average
GMB
that was sexy
Stephanie k
creepy creepy Jarrell jam and J Leanne
Jay that has been creepy or sexy with
Ryan and Michael we should do that every
episode
Jim and Jay Lee and Jay Luna R Mike F
Stonehenge Brian L Kendall L Kara C
Jessica B Kyle F Marisol
Kaylee J creepy Mickey L not Kaylee
you're not creepy I am Brian a Mickey L
Ashley F Marion Louise lyfus like
Dreyfus Romeo B just remember Romeo's
bleeding the movie he'll be Veronica Q
Frank B Jen T Nikki L Alan H April R
Cassie B Derek n j d w Michelle L thanks
to all the newcomers for supporting me
and the podcast we love you uh
patreon.com inside of you thank you all
we love you very much and uh Michael
Rosemount I'm here in the Hollywood
Hills California I'm Ryan Taylor's in
the Hollywood Hills of California
hey guys we love you be good to yourself
foreign